so welcome to the inaugural event of the
Harriman Institute project on human
rights in the post-communist world
strategies and outcomes so the
post-communist region is one that has
undergone experiences that provide
lessons about strategies for promoting
human rights part of the post-communist
world has human rights flourishing to a
degree that it never has before but in
other parts of the post-communist world
human rights are under serious attack so
this gives us a broad range of variation
and outcomes to think about what what
causes these differences in outcomes and
to what extent are those differences
caused by different strategies of people
who want to promote human rights so
especially in the project which is
co-organized by Alexandra Cooley a
professor at Barnard College political
science department and myself we're
looking at what strategies of rights
promotion are effective what are the
theories of change underlying the
strategies of Rights promotion that
underpin and guide these approaches what
are the variation of outcomes and
compliance with rights standards and how
are they measured by the various
organizations like freedom house or
transparency international what have you
that have devised techniques for
measuring these outcomes and what are
the consequences of the booming cottage
industry of these rating and ranking
organizations in the areas of democracy
corruption legality and so forth so in
the project
we're going to start with a few
presentations that look at the big
picture theories of change in a global
and comparative context including our
session tonight with Katherine siccing
and then in the course of the year we're
going to move on to more events that are
very specifically about the
post-communist world that will be
evaluated in the light of these concepts
that we're going to be starting to
grapple with tonight so tonight in a
week from tonight we have two of the
most high profile and rigorous thinkers
in the area of Human Rights strategies
and evaluation of their success tonight
we have Catherine sick Inc who's a
professor in the political science
department at the University of
Minnesota she's the book of the author
of the very famous book activists Beyond
Borders which together with her other
work I think it's fair to say basically
created the modern field of Human Rights
studies in the discipline of political
science and has won prestigious awards
such as the gravimeter award for World
Order and now she's completing a new
book that uses some of the approaches
she developed earlier in her
award-winning book applying it to the
question of international criminal
justice the book the Justice cascade
which will be appearing next summer from
norton books in which you'll get a
preview of tonight we're especially
proud of Catherine here at Columbia
because she's a Columbia PhD so always
great to have her back and we can take
credit and bask in her glory just a
little advertisement for next week Beth
Simmons who's a professor in the
government department
at Harvard will be giving a talk on her
award-winning book on October 20th at
five thirty different venue it's going
to be in 1501 international affairs
building and she's going to be talking
about mobilizing for human rights her
discussants will be Ken Roth the
President of Human Rights Watch and Alex
Cooley so tonight Kathryn is going to
talk for about 35 minutes and we have
two excellent discussants Richard dicker
is here the director of the Human Rights
Watch international justice program and
our other discussant is Robert Cohan is
a professor of Public and International
Affairs at Princeton University past
president of the American Political
Science Association and the the winner
of the poll for who's the most
influential scholar of international
relations like year in and year out so
we're happy to have these two
discussants because one of our
objectives in this series is to get a
good dialogue going between academics
and practitioners on these issues of
Human Rights strategies and so you know
let it begin tonight now one other
advertisement before I let Catherine
take the floor which is that if you're
interested in transitional justice as a
topic we have another great panel for
you coming up on februari 10th 515 in
1501 international affairs building that
day where we're going to hear from for
scholars who have new book projects on
transitional justice in Eastern Europe
and elsewhere Lauren nettle field who is
one of the fellows in our project this
year and is here raise your head Lara
rooty title who invented the term
transitional justice Monica Nalepa and
Leslie avenge amore will present their
research and their discussants will be
rea Nayar the founder of Human Rights
Watch and the president of the open
society institute and Tina Rosenberg who
won the national book award for her book
on the subject so februari 10th you
transitional justice aficionados don't
don't miss that one so now Katherine
please tell us about your exciting new
bar well first thank you very much Jack
for for arranging this event and for the
gracious over-the-top introduction it's
really a pleasure for me to it's always
a pleasure for me to be back here at
Columbia University I want to have
special thanks to Richard dicker into
Robert co hain for agreeing to come for
taking the time to read the manuscript
the whole manuscript intent and come
today to comment on it and I impact in
completing my revisions for Norton at
the end of October so I'm exactly at the
point where I could take advantage of
last minute to suggestions and comments
so I welcome those of the commentators
and also the audience this book i'm
actually trying to write it
simultaneously for an academic audience
and for the general public and I that I
think is clear to the people who read
the manuscript it won't be so clear
today in my presentation but I tell a
lot of stories of the real people behind
the Justice cascade in this book the
basic focus is that over the last three
decades countries are increasingly using
criminal trials to hold past state
officials accountable for human rights
violations and I argued quite a few
years ago with my colleague Ellen Lutz
that this was an important and new
phenomenon
in international politics and we called
it the Justice cascade and that's the
term I'm now using for this book and by
the justice cascade we didn't mean that
true justice was being done everywhere
in the world so let me first I know the
opposition always comes saying but true
justice has not been done so you are
wrong there's no justice cascade I'm
using that term from legal theorist Cass
Sunstein who developed the term enormous
cade by which he meant that there was a
new legitimacy that there's new
legitimacy to norms in this case norms
around individual criminal
accountability which we see through the
increasing use of criminal prosecutions
at the international domestic and
foreign level now the the research
questions for the book then are why why
this new trend why are state officials
being held accountable for human rights
violations through criminal prosecutions
when that did not happen before what
effects do these prosecutions have and
in particular can human rights trials
reduce human rights violations we
presume that's the main purpose of such
prosecutions is prevention and the
question is or deterrence do they have a
deterrent effect and then finally can
this case help us think about important
theoretical debates in the social
sciences about norm emergence norm
diffusion compliance with international
law deterrence of international crime
and of course the big question that Jack
introduced how do we explain change in
international politics now question
number one really is has two separate
questions and that is how do these new
this new trend first emerged how do
those first countries that carry out
prosecutions decide to do it when it
hasn't been done before and then uh you
know how do these you know why and how
do these practices spread or diffuse and
I really realize have to working on the
book for a while those are two quite
different questions that require
different explanations
um just to give you an idea the Conte of
the the contents the table contents of
the book is organized around these three
questions what how do we create how does
the trend towards individual criminal
accountability emerge um how do these
ideas spread and then finally I do human
rights prosecution's make a difference
do they have an impact and you'll note
that that section of the book has three
separate chapters one looks at the
impact in Latin America where I've done
a lot of work and which has been the
earliest and most frequent user of these
kinds of prosecutions the second reports
on a study I've done with a colleague
hon chan kim which is a statistical
global statistical analysis of the
impact of prosecutions around the world
and the third takes up the important
case of the United States because as
soon as you say oh there's a new norm
out there people ask the important and
obvious question well if there's really
a new norm does it have an impact for
powerful states in the world what
difference does it make for the United
States or for China or for the Soviet
Union and chetna for example and so I
take up the case specifically looking at
Bush administration non-compliance with
torture with the prohibition of torture
non-compliance with the prohibition of
torture and I ask what difference if any
did the Justice cascade have for Bush
administration policy now I'm not going
to talk about that during my
presentation today because I'm going to
rush you through this whole book but I
would be very happy to field questions
about that during the
question-and-answer period now the the
historical argan I'm making is that
there's three models of accountability
and I'm you taking a definition of
accountability from Robert Co hainan and
Ruth grants very well-known article on
that topic that says that the definition
is that some actors have the right to
hold other actors to account and they do
it through a variety of means and
legal accountability is not the only
form of accountability I'm nevertheless
arguing that prior to World War two
there was something i call the sovereign
immunity model and that simply that
state and state officials were not held
accountable for human past human rights
violations there are a few exceptions to
that rule but it's mainly the rule after
World War Two and largely in response to
the failure of the sovereign immunity
model to prevent the Holocaust and other
human rights violations during the war
the something I call the state
accountability model emerged this is
virtually the entire United Nations
system works around a state
accountability model as do the Regional
Human Rights courts in the Americas or
in Europe where if the European Court of
Human Rights find that a state is not
meeting its obligations under the
european convention it asks that state
to change its policy or to provide
redress and so the state itself is held
accountable but individuals are not and
then thirdly and the topic my book of
course is the individual criminal
accountability model begins to emerge in
the 70s in the 80s where for the first
time individual state officials are held
legally accountable now the argument
here is not that the criminal model is
replacing or supplanting these other
models rather they continue to exist
side by side my too close to this mike
is that with giving us a feedback okay
they continue to exist side by side so
basically in the in the world today I
would argue we have all three of these
models continue to exist and function
together but what is new is in three
decades is the emergence of this
criminal account individual criminal
accountability model now to write the
book we decided to produce a database
because there are a lot of big arguments
about this these issues and they were
being debated mainly on the basis of
case studies individual case studies and
so we created a database of human rights
prosecutions in the world I just want to
briefly give you an overview of that
database first it's a database of
prosecutions
three levels international prosecutions
like the ICC the International Criminal
Court the ICTY foreign or transnational
prosecutions in the most famous of those
being the prosecution of Pinot jet in
the United Kingdom for crimes pitted in
Chile and then finally domestic
prosecutions international legal
scholars and Nash relation scholars have
paid the most attention to the
international prosecution part of this
story but when you see the database
you'll see that most of the action is
actually occurring in domestic courts
excellent books have been written on on
each of these topics you know Laura
nettle fields book about the icty you're
going to hear about in February for
example books about the ICC books about
single sets of trials in Argentina
what's been missing I believe is the big
picture that there is the emergence of a
decentralized but interactive system of
accountability the involving
prosecution's at all three levels so
this is just a brief summary of the the
data in the database these are the
numbers annual numbers of prosecution
years you see we have here the forum the
International the domestic and then the
total and then here is a cumulative
prosecution years by types and I think
this then makes evident kind of what we
mean when we say that there's a cascade
of sorts here this dramatic increase and
also the dark the dark black is the
domestic trials so I also think it makes
clear that a lot of the criminal
prosecution is happening in domestic
courts for crimes committed in human
rights violations committed in that
country just one other interesting fact
about the database about domestic
prosecution's is that it's very
regionally concentrated so even though
this is a global phenomena because there
are criminal prosecutions for human
rights violations in all regions of the
world it has been concentrated in
certain regions and especially in the
Emir
cuz and in Central and Eastern Europe
and so because I originally worked on
Latin America I started following this
trend very early back in 1985 actually I
was writing in Argentina writing my
dissertation on a totally different
topic and it was the year that the
trials of the juntos were happening in
argentina and i was able doing that
entire year to witness some of the most
important and earliest trials of
high-level officials for past human
rights violations now the turn to the
first question why does it justice
cascade emerge basically and one of the
things I found is that this regional
pattern I just showed you is because of
justice cascade emerged in regions where
regional human rights law and
institutions were already in place
especially Europe and the Americas so
this is also these are also the regions
that experience the early part of the
third wave of democratization the
countries that adopted early
prosecutions were also places that had
domestic and regional Human Rights
networks that were strong and so people
who know my earlier work won't be
surprised once again some of the
protagonists here are these human rights
organizations these human rights
networks that push for Human Rights
prosecutions but once you have those in
place there are some countries that
adopt prosecutions in some countries
that don't and one of the factors it's
very important for early adopters of
such prosecutions is that they had a
ruptured a transition to democracy and
that's the term comparative politics
folks use to about talk about
transitions to democracy usually it
means that there was a war and and the
previous regime lost the war like the
lens or malvinas warn argentina in
the case of Greece there was the
military debacle in Cyprus and in doing
so they weaken
and their own power and we're not able
to dictate the terms of the transition
they were not able to dictate terms that
basically protect themselves from
prosecution in the new regime and
countries that had packed 'add
transitions the power holders were able
to set the terms and were able to rule
out prosecutions and so that factor
turns to be an important factor predict
early adopters of trials so for example
this is why we get the earliest trials
in greece and in portugal both had
ruptured transitions not in spain that
had a transition in the same region
around the same time but did not have
any prosecutions it helps explain why we
get prosecutions in Argentina and
Bolivia both with ruptured transitions
but not in countries like Uruguay or
Brazil that had transitions around the
same time but did not initially use
prosecutions and then the other factor
that's very interesting I think about
the conditions is once it became
possible to imagine accountability and
what's hard to go back and remember
because we just take for granted now day
of course of course people will think
about individual criminal accountability
but when I first interviewed human
rights activists in Argentina when did
they first make that demand a one person
told me he goes he remembers early
meetings where he went to the gathering
of human rights activists who are
planning a demonstration and they're
trying to decide whether they dare put
the word justice in a banner in in a
slogan and he and he suggests justice
and his fellow activist eight are you
crazy are you a provocator you know we
can't ask for justice and yet only three
years later in Argentina the demand was
queasy Oh castigo de la kebab lees ok
justice and punishment for all the
guilty ok a maximalist human rights
demand had happened and so we sometimes
forget that it was perceived as
dangerous risky demand it was almost
unimaginable for many even for the
victims even for the activists
it was unimaginable that actually state
officials could be held individually
criminally accountable for human rights
violations and so what transformed was
not just that these trials happen but a
whole transformation of the very
imagination of what was possible and so
when people began to think it might be
possible to prosecute they turn to a
familiar domestic analogy they turn to
criminal law from their domestic legal
system and and norms theories has said
that before they said that domestic
norms are very often used to think about
norms in the international system I
think in this case that the four lawyers
for judges at fort for victims it was
once they thought it was possible to
have accountability the obvious solution
seemed to be the criminal accountability
system that they were already using in
their domestic judicial system in
virtually every country of the world so
now this is my attempt at a and Richard
rigor hasn't seen this one yet so I want
his reaction to it I don't think
obviously it either this is my attempt
to do a better visual for chapter 4 for
those of you who've read that book and
it's also my attempt because um chapter
4 is about the Cascade itself if you
wish how this idea takes off and spreads
around the world and and norton wanted
me to take out the part about
international law too much about
drafting those boring treaties and no
one will want to read this book and so I
took the argument that um that I
discovered as I was looking at the
spread of these ideas is there was not
one justice cascade there were various
to keep the water metaphor streams that
flowed into the justice cascade and in
particular there were these two streams
one that came the international tribunal
a stream that's coming along the top
there and there was a separate stream
that were these domestic and foreign
prosecution
I've been talking about and initially
those two streams didn't interact and so
if you ask international lawyer or you
ask someone who's worked at the icty or
help set up the icty and you say what's
the origin the icty and they say
nuremberg and that's all they say never
maybe Tokyo maybe Eichmann okay but they
don't mention ever the domestic trials
so they tell just this international
story actually Richard dicker will I
hope will tell a story later on but
initially after Nuremberg it wasn't that
the first possible case wasn't going to
be the former Yugoslavia the first
possible case might have been Iraq and
there was interest in seeing whether
there could be a case brought against
Iraq for the genocide of the Kurds that
have failed so the next internet
revealing becomes the icty the ictr and
then eventually moves towards the ICC
meanwhile at the same time we have these
domestic prosecution's moving ahead on
this totally separate stream and but
these two streams begin to converge and
they begin to converge at the rome
meeting to draft the statute of the
international criminal court and they
converge because countries come to rome
by about 30 countries by the time
actually maybe slightly more than that
come who have already practiced domestic
prosecutions in their country and they
are present at rome and that experience
with domestic prosecutions informs their
participation in rome so the streams
begin to come together but then finally
at the bottom you see this part that
norton wants me to take out that i'm
trying to justify and the point is this
the point is that these the critique of
Nuremberg was at Nuremberg was Victor's
justice that Nuremberg was retroactive
justice and so in order to make the
Justice cascade stick in order to make
it a permanent feature of the national
system you had to build hard law as its
underpinning and so again i use probably
worn metaphor by this point you had to
build the streambed this hard law stream
bed underneath the Justice cascade
these dreams in order to give it this
legal underpinning that would make it
not Victor's justice not retroactive
justice and to make it a more enduring
feature of the national system and that
was done starting really with the
Genocide Convention and the Geneva
Conventions but it really took steam in
the 80s with the drafting of the
Convention Against Torture and with the
draft and Convention Against Torture you
have entering in finally what some
people are calling the individualization
of international law or the
criminalization of international law in
other words finally the individual
really takes his or her place in
international law and previously states
had always been the privileged actors
international law individuals had not
played an important role and it's
through very much the actions of penal
lawyers the association here isn't a
professional association association of
Pinot lawyers that start working to get
this language about individuals as
objects and subjects of a national law
that begins to really appear in the
torture convention so now so this is
actually trying to explain the argument
about the the main argument the book and
the notion is that what were these
streams are coming together and there we
are in we have emerging system of a
decentralized interactive system of
global accountability it's decentralized
because decisions are being taken in
many different places mainly in domestic
judicial systems by domestic judges and
prosecutors who are not coordinating
their decisions with others it's
interactive because the decision taking
one place has an impact and interacts
with decisions taking elsewhere the most
obvious the clearest example of this for
me is always a Penta Chet case amnesty
laws in Chile closed down the Chilean
justice system to victims they took the
case to the United Kingdom that led to
the arrest of
in London the one spinach as arrest in
London the Chilean's do everything
possible to show that he can be tried
back at home and so judicial and
political changes are made back in Chile
so that domestic prosecution's can move
ahead that I think illustrates is
interactive nature of it of these levels
the Criminal Court of course embodies
this interactivity in the doctrine of
complementarity but I mean interactivity
beyond complementarity rather you might
take the word complementarity and think
of it as being a metaphor for the
largest system whether it's operating in
relation to the ICC or not so under what
conditions then does this model diffuse
or spread their background conditions
include the end of the Cold War and the
third wave of democracy so even though
the spreading starts before the end of
the Cold War it really does take off in
this period really between the end of
the Cold War and the beginning of the
war on terror the reigning orthodoxy
which is both the immunity in the state
accountability model are increasingly
seen as broken or failed and this is
very important in the context of the
Balkans and Rhonda so the appearance of
genocide in the heart of Europe 50 years
after the Holocaust and closely followed
by a terrible genocide in Africa where
the international community seems unable
to respond are seen as a kind of shocked
that suggests the system is broken or
failed in some way and that we need some
new elements to address it and and this
gives a push to a to individual criminal
accountability as an additional tool in
the tool case of people concerned about
justice now some people initially said
oh that was just that was just guilt
there was so much guilt over failures
that they were doing kind of a band-aid
approach by setting up these tribunals
um but I think that ignore is the degree
to which this was real political action
that could have real
t'kul consequences now again norm
entrepreneurs actively work to defuse
this model diffusion is usually a
passive verb things diffuse but here
norm but entrepreneurs diffuse these
norms not just advocacy networks but
advocacy networks working together
especially with networks trans
governmental networks in like minded
states and sometimes epidemic
communities of legal professionals like
these penal law folks and so the
sometimes these trans global networks
included the United States as in the
creation of the icty where the US was an
important player sometimes powerful
states like they like the United States
or China were adamantly opposed to these
developments like with the creation of
the International Criminal Court so this
is what these transnational networks
were not necessarily networks of
powerful state imposing their norms or
values on the rest of the world okay I'm
turning to question three I want to make
sure we have plenty of time for my
commentators so I'm rushing a bit but
hopefully we'll have time to come back
to questions turning to to a question 3
what difference what do these trials
make are they effective are they not
effective the answer that question first
year to say what you mean by
effectiveness and people trying to
answer the question of the effectiveness
of these tribunals have used many many
different criteria have held these
tribunals up too many high goals high
and lofty goals um I'm going to focus
just really on one of these today and
that is the first and that is do
criminal individual criminal
prosecutions lead to improvements in
human rights the there's a lot of
theories out there about this in
political science there's a couple of
mainstream theories that suggest that
unless and norm has enforcement it's not
going to have an effect and i conceive
of these kind of prosecutions as a form
of enforcement that we know the human
rights regime had lots of treaties and
not many teeth finally you've got some
teeth through these prosecutions and so
people like downs and Rockne and others
would suggest that when you get
enforcement you're more likely to see
effectiveness there this is also
connects to deterrence theory in
sociology which is that an increase in
the likelihood of punishment should lead
to a decrease in crime now deterrence
theory is very often I think erroneously
only associated with severity of
punishment and I and so whenever I say
that they have to say I know you've all
heard about the death penalty you're
going to raise your hand and start
saying we all know the death penalty
doesn't deter crime the point I want to
make you is this deterrence theory
involves two factors the likelihood of
punishment and the severity of
punishment and quantitative research on
deterrence suggests that there is
support that increases in the likelihood
of punishment lead to a decrease in
crime there is not such support for
notions about severity of punishment and
we might think of that when we debate
issues about severity of sentences in
these international tribunals the
victims care very deeply about severe
sentences but it's not clear that more
severe sentences will deter crime I
think it's it is an important hypothesis
that the a greater likelihood of
punishment might deter crime the
international community was if you wish
and environments like a natural
experiment for deterrence theory because
they under the impunity model there was
zero likelihood of punishment if you
were state official if you carried our
human rights violations you could
anticipate a zero likelihood that you
would be punished individually
criminally for your activity and in
these
30 years he's last 30 years we've moved
from a zero likelihood of punishment to
some positive some varies from country
to country and varies from region to
region and so I think it's actually a
very interesting time to ask about the
relevance of deterrence theory there's
other theories that predict a negative
effect of trials so a democracy shin
theory has long said that you know
really worries that prosecutions are
going to undermine these fragile
democracies and Jack Snyder and his
co-author have made compelling arguments
that under certain conditions and
particularly Civil War conditions that
demands for prosecutions are likely to
lead to a worsening of human rights
violations and are likely to undermine
democracy and perhaps exacerbate
conflict and so it's been a lively
debate check and I've been going on on
this event I don't know five six seven
years now right and we've been having
this argument so it's it's fun to
continue the argument with Jack so in
order to address this we use the
database and particularly we compared
transitional countries that had a trial
experience this is the bottom dark line
with transitional countries that had no
trial experience and so basically trying
to instead of using case studies which
had been mainly used to this point we
try to use and comparisons empirical
such as comparisons of countries that
had trials with those who did not i
should say that the folds of disco
analysis again done with a co-author hon
chan kim who is the expert in statistics
I am NOT we will be published by
international studies quarterly in an
article this December and so anyone who
would like the full regression tables
those will be available to you in
December within the journal is Q I'm
going to present to you just some very
basic just a very basic kind of snapshot
summary of the findings so this top a
table is comparing okay the repression
score so people who are not familiar
there's a large
quantitative literature on human rights
these days it uses a repression score
that's coded by researchers from Amnesty
International and reports and from State
Department annual country Human Rights
reports okay so it's a number there's
two different measures ones from zero to
125 and ones from back again here and
one is from a eight so what this is
showing is the what this is showing here
this middle gray line is showing the
global mean that's a global repression
mean of trent of transitional countries
okay how much average repression to
these transitional countries have in our
database the dotted line here is the the
countries with no trial experience okay
countries and no trial experience and
the dash dark dash line is a country
it's with trial experience and so
basically what this is showing is that
the average repression score countries
with no trial experience the higher
number here in repression is greater in
kind of in a stable way greater after
about 1994 then the states with a trial
experience down here in the second table
we're trying to compare the global mean
here we're trying to compare countries
with just one trial year to come to
states with multiple trial years it's a
little bit harder to see but again we
have the global mean line here and then
we have states with one trial year which
is this kind of zigzaggy dotted line and
the states with multiple trial years
this dash this lower dashed line and so
again and art our statistical nails and
regression tables support this that
their countries that are more persistent
with their use of prosecutions seem to
see a bit a bigger improvement in their
human rights a situation so basically
the three main conclusions that come
from the statistical analysis
our first that our first that countries
that have used human rights prosecutions
it appears to be associated with
improvements in human rights what we
don't know yet exactly are the
mechanisms through which these
prosecutions translate into improved
human rights so we don't actually know
whether it's deterrence whether it's
punishment or whether it's what Laura
and others have been referred to as the
expressive nature of law okay trials of
course are not just punishment trials
are high-profile symbolic events that
communicate and dramatize norms and so
we don't know what's doing the work
probably both the this increase in the
likelihood of punishment or this this
expressing the norm communicating
performing these norms second we found
that this holds even in situations of
civil war now mind you civil war makes
human rights worse we're not saying it
doesn't civil wars is consistently the
best predictor of bad human rights
conditions but when you add actual
prosecutions to a civil war situation it
doesn't seem to make it even worse and
then the third and maybe the most
intriguing finding we have is something
we call deterrence across borders and
that is that countries that are in a
region where their neighbors have used
lots of Human Rights prosecutions see
some kind of improvement in their human
rights even if they themselves have not
used prosecutions and so there would
appear to be that you know when you sit
in Uruguay and you look across the river
plate at trials in Argentina even if
you're not having trials of your own
military it appears to have an impact in
your country okay well let me just turn
to just some final conclusions I want to
have to I would have talked a little
about policy implications here in
theoretical implications you know one
policy implication is just that
that the I believe that these Human
Rights prosecutions are a now well
established in domestic law and practice
international and international law and
practice I don't think they're going to
go away I don't think they're ephemeral
and partly they're not so because
they're well grounded in this legal in
this firm legal stream bed of hard law
also with many years of experience some
of the fear and the risk the early
prosecution's provoked has evaporated
okay so when the when there was a coup
attempt against the Argentine government
when was attempting trials everyone was
very afraid everyone thought these
trials are dangerous but now 25 years
later many many countries around the
world and particularly many countries in
Latin America have used these
prosecutions and at least in Latin
America there has been no successful
coup attempt ever as a result of
prosecutions and so it has diminished
fears now fear still exists for example
in the United States the day you still
hear many people saying it's way too
dangerous it's way too risky for us to
be able to prosecute Bush administration
officials for torture during the Bush
administration and my main my feeling
about this is lots of good political
reasons why a country might choose not
to hold prosecutions I certainly do not
say every country must immediately hold
Human Rights prosecutions okay I believe
that that countries need to consider
their political circumstances and make
decisions about transitional justice
what I don't what i have left patience
for is that officials want to use causal
arguments about conflict in order to
justify the decisions they want to say
no we can't hold prosecutions because
will undermine our democracy because it
will provoke war because it will because
it will exacerbate human rights
practices so i want to say no there's
actually not good evidence of that so if
you politically you feel you can't do it
then politically say you know trials are
unpopular will lose them it
elections but but I don't I think
country should not be dressing up their
political reasons with social science
arguments theoretically what I'd like to
conclude is that part of what I'm saying
here is stuff that's very familiar to
people who have followed my work before
okay so once again we have the
individual criminal accountability norm
goes through the norm life cycle that
Martha Finnemore and I described many
years ago in an article once again the
norm entrepreneurs are an important
necessary condition to help explain the
emerges and the spread of the of this
new norm but I think there's some new
material here too and for a long time
I've argued that in order to explain
real world experiences we are often
going to need to combine the ideational
theory that comes from constructivism
with more rationalist explanations and I
think that this case offers a really
good example of how that works so for
example the norm of individual criminal
accountability depends on these norm
entrepreneurs but the countries that can
be the early adopters of those norms our
countries like Greece or Argentine or
Portugal where the spoilers and power
holders have been weakened okay but and
here's maybe where deck and I have a
disagreement but eventually as the
cascade proceeds that condition is no
longer necessary ok so the domestic
conditions of weakened power the weekend
power holders in that's there for early
adopters but the diffusion phenomena is
such that at a certain point your
domestic conditions are less important
and what's more important to explain
whether or not you use prosecutions is
how many other countries in your region
are using prosecutions so we get an
imitation phenomena that's more
important than whether or not you have
you lost your power holders lost at war
and that's what's really interesting
about these diffusion phenomena secondly
another way in
which I think kind of rationalist in
constructivists arguments interact here
is on one hand the norm entrepreneurs
are pressing for the emergence of this
of this new law and yet at the same time
one of the mechanisms through which I
believe one of the Meccans but I can't
prove it yet through which the law
translates into prevention is a
punishment is the likelihood of
punishment is real costs imposed on
perpetrators and the fear that future
perpetrators have that they their career
could suffer they could be put in jail
whatever and so there is a combination
here of ideational factors that are
working with more material or more
rationalist factors to explain this this
outcome so let me end there and just
them I'm thank you again for coming and
I'm so pleased that I'll have the
remarks from my two commentators
thanks Kathryn that was a great example
of what I was hoping we could accomplish
here and have a rigorous social science
analysis that would really engage the
issues that practitioners are concerned
every day so we have our two
commentators to God we're going to begin
with Richard dicker here's directs the
Rights Watch program on international
justice and mother thinks he's the guy
that the new york i called up when they
needed whoa hey what do you think of the
legal process in the trial of malta
bitch or sit down the same so what do
you think well i won't attempt to
translate that into a sound bite at this
moment oh wait for the reviewers to go
from the new york times but um let me
make a couple of points based on the
text first and foremost from my
perspective as a practitioner the
Justice cascade could not be more timely
and more important to an intense and
what I regard to be rather high stakes
fight that's taking place in the realm
of international politics and prep and
practice and specifically what I mean is
we're at a moment when the ad hoc
tribunal see Yugoslavia beuno Rwanda
tribunal are in the process of closing
down pretty much leaving the
International Criminal Court as likely
the soul into
national institution dispensing justice
and its mandate the Mandate of the court
is under very very sharp attack and one
need only refer to the situations where
the court is carrying out investigations
and has issued arrest warrants to see
the the truth of that assertion in
Darfur for example the arrest warrant
against Sudanese President Omar
al-bashir has triggered an intense and
to use Katherine's term vituperative a
debate and backlash against justice in
the Congo an outstanding arrest warrant
against a Congolese warlord who is now a
general in the Congolese armed forces
has prompted both the president and just
last week the Justice Minister to say
peace trumps justice at this point and
we are not going to arrest Bosco
Ntaganda I would predict in Kenya where
the court has just opened an
investigation when the arrest warrants
for high-ranking officials connected
with the post-election violence in Kenya
when those are issued and even before we
will hear from Kenyan officials that
these arrest warrants jeopardized
prospects for the 2012 election so these
are real questions that have in a sense
in some instances paralyzed in other
instances mobilized international
organizations like the United Nations
the European Union the African Union and
others so this research is invaluable
from
practical sense and I would just stop on
that note by drawing your attention to
the fact that the International Criminal
Court has a mandate that is different
than the Yugoslavia Wanda Sierra Leone
special courts in that its mandate
allows it to conduct investigations into
ongoing conflicts where justice is on
the table at the same time as other
important but very different diplomatic
and political objectives such as
negotiating a peace agreement or
deploying peacekeeping forces to protect
populations at risk as in Darfur so so
timely so important i think the
methodology and the conclusions that
that catherine has drawn are very
important for the reason that the debate
I believe has grown stale in other words
in the face of the Justice cascade that
the book describes we have seen and I
don't mean to be unfair here from the
peace mediation community a kind of
reflexive reaction not only that justice
makes their work of negotiating an end
to conflict more difficult but rather as
as catherine referred to justice is a
dangerous element in up ending the
prospects for peace as i said and and it
is an extremely intense debate and i
think there is an intense need for new
facts to be put on the table that
reflect a sophisticated and rigorous
research methodology to kind of stir
this debate and advance it forward now I
won't advertise Human Rights Watch's
report entitled selling justice short
I'm glad to talk to you about
on the side I don't want to take
attention away from the main act but
some research we did based on 20 years
of fact-finding to make some of the
points in the less compelling and and
well researched way than Katherine does
but there is a crying need for new
analysis and new facts on this debate to
in this debate to take on the arguments
now I I want to conclude by teasing out
from from the book a couple of points
that are implicit and make them more
explicit one the uneven distribution of
justice and your last chapter of course
deals with the United States and the
reaction and practice of the Bush
administration let me say that it's an
ugly fact and reality that we
practitioners have to recognize
particularly those of us based here in
New York or in Paris or in London that
the playing field is very uneven when it
comes to the application of justice and
there's no better example of that
unevenness then one the opposition of
the previous administration to the
International Criminal Court and the
practices that the administration
engaged in in regard to torture and the
lack of likely judicial remedies for
victims of those practices that
indicates one a huge gap in the reach of
justice and to to those and particularly
I can say from my own experience in
Addis Ababa at the African Union gives
opponents of justice quite a card to
play by pointing to the lack of reach of
justice to the bushes the rumsfeld's as
well as
to the Putin's and others responsible
for crimes in in Chechnya de I don't
want to strike an anti-american note
here as if it's only Washington that is
insulated itself from the reach of
justice the same can very well be said
of Moscow land and this uneven
application where the leaders of the
most powerful states and those they
protect our immune from justice is an
ugly reality that also undercuts the
legitimacy of the norm in those parts of
the world that have experienced horrific
human rights violations for which there
has been zero accountability I'm
thinking of Africa under colonial rule
as one example all right and many many
many other places second to last point I
think the the Cascade you know which has
a powerful image you know I fear as a
practitioner who's very much on the
defensive in a sense wearing my flak
jacket to work every day trying to fight
off this and that assault on justice
mechanisms I feel there's a fragility in
the norm that is rooted in the fact that
states will readily jettison justice in
order to advance diplomatic and
political objectives and that justice
while it is a norm is a weak norm
compared to the traditional values and
objectives of statecraft concretely what
that means is when the Security Council
is more interested in a peace settlement
it will become much less interested in
seeing the arrest warrants for the
tribunals itself created actually
executed whether that's in Bosnia or
whether that's in dark
for so justice it's fragile gets
jettisoned and that also serves to
undercut I fear its legitimacy last
question that you haven't really
addressed in the book and and and maybe
there's no snow scope to do so but
really what are some of the scenarios
that could unfold I agree with you that
we're not going to have a reversal to
the pre-1945 point by no means I mean
that train has left the station and it's
not going back the the treaties despite
what Norton might argue with you are
very important in creating that
international law screen bed that you
refer to what I fear is not the total
reversal but in a sense the
marginalization that the norm becomes
more respected in its dishonor than in
its application and as you say in the
book justice is such a particular
particularly a motive and in some ways
emotional norm it generates such
expectations I fear that we are looking
at a possibility I wouldn't say
probability that the Justice cascade
could be tamed and and marginalized and
made to be luck much less of an actor or
force rather on the international
terrain and thus lose some of its
legitimacy and some of its force that I
think is the worst case scenario not
reversal but to me day to day it's a
real possibility thank you
I'm gonna refer to one of those the last
figure at some point okay the Justice of
Cascade is an immensely engaging account
of a scholars own personal journey and a
and of how to combine moral passion with
systemic social science and it's a
fascinating analysis of how the movement
to hold state leaders personally
responsible for crimes began in spread
it has an optimistic and progressive
tone that is a wonderful antidote to the
pervasive cynicism of much of the
professional literature in political
science as well as the media students
and other readers under the age of 45
will not only gain an understanding of
the origins and diffusion of a human
rights movement but they might otherwise
take for granted they will gain insights
into the process of international
relations scholarship and it's best I'm
definitely going to assign this book in
my international law and politics
seminar the only real question is
whether I can bear to delay it to my
section on human rights law and
accountability or whether it should be
the the first weeks reading to signal
why the subject is so exciting well i
think it's a it's a wonderful book and i
only a little bit disturbed that you
took seriously what your editor is said
about what you should write i never let
editor say what the right or to
emphasize in the old saying about policy
experts editors should be on tap not on
top you tell them what to do they don't
tell you what to do you're a scholar and
they aren't so you're above them and so
I don't don't don't let him tell you
what to do well justice cascade also as
many analytical virtues it traces the
origins of the emerging norm that former
state leaders should be studied a
prosecution for acts committed on their
authority win an office which is
Catherine shows and it said here is a
very novel claim and it achieves all
these results that you've seen in an
eclectic way in particular Catherine
refutes three pernicious dichotomies and
the bane of international asians theory
right now is
economy stupid false dichotomies and
Katherine doesn't engage in this in fact
refutes three of them she refutes that
economy between deterrence and norms
that economy between punishment and
truth commissions and the grand economy
of all the dumbest of all realism versus
blank in this case realism versus
constructivism no one in the right mind
I think who studies international
politics believes that realism is all
false it's a lot of truth in that but
nobody I think in the right mind
believes it's the whole truth either and
the notion that these are alternative
views you have to choose between them is
about the silliest thing I've ever heard
and it still is it pervades the
international engine which is the most
depressing thing about my field Kathryn
shows how various streams of events came
together to change the impunity norm and
how a variety of different mechanisms
seem to enhance the effectiveness of
trials and furthermore she's modest in
in her texts she indicates they're her
conclusion about the trials the
effectiveness is challenged by others
and should be viewed as tentative
pending further analysis so all these
accomplishments would make the Justice
cascade very important if even if it
were not so engaging I have only one
serious question about the inference
that that you make about effectiveness
that's why I want this this up and then
i have several other more general points
to make about implications of the
analysis the big analytical problem with
the argument that trials are effective
which is indicated suggested by this
chart is what we call on political
science and dodge annuity that is the
trials could be a symptom of deeper
underlying causes it could be that this
could be this fall could be right but
the trials could not be causally
important at all they could reflect
something and katherine or text is
explicit about this but there are some
intriguing problems in the in the figure
this figure that i saw in your
manuscript went back to nineteen eighty
and this one starts 1987 that's
important because then when I comment on
the manuscript I pointed out that the
dash line there
line which begins if you go back to 80
it begins at a very low point almost
your aunt's deeply rises to meet the
other lines in other words states that
later have trials are those in which
repression increased dramatically in the
first half of 1980s so these states the
states at later have trials are
different and you mentioned this before
in your talk to are different from the
states that that didn't later have
trials and I imagine this finding is
probably driven by latin america
argentina uruguay El Salvador Guatemala
but what it does suggest is what we call
lack of unit homogeneity in there in the
in the repressive states that is they
aren't all alike and there may be
something specifically different about
the states that both had what might be
called late repression that is
repression went way up from a low point
from nineteen eighty to eighty seven
which is what then if that dash line
were shown from 1980 that's what it
would show it would go from 1980 very
low levels of repression up to meet the
point you see it at in 1987 and so these
states may be different that is they
that's what we call omitted variables
there's something else about these
states that could be driving the results
which is correlated with but not
causally associated with the outcome an
obvious candidate is a previous recent
history of democracy and I want to ask
you about that that is there the states
that had trials and therefore and that
later do better are also states that
were more democratic earlier so as an
obvious candidate which is the
independent of trials trials could be
inconsequential the obvious candidate is
a previously history of democracy
there's still the existence of civil
society groups that are going to press
for them for democracy and they enlist
in this story are temporarily eclipsed
by these repressive military regimes but
they come back and so as they come back
they bounce back repression Falls
nothing could be nothing to do with
trials so the causal mechanisms in my
view are not clear it's pretty clear
that trials don't
of a disastrous effect because then
you'd have a different pattern but it's
not clear that the trials are doing the
cause of work for you so I think that I
would make that clear distinction what
you've shown is that trials are not
having a negative disastrous effect I
think you have not shown that trials are
making a positive difference now for
more general themes that I wanted to to
just a signal because the book is so
good at at touching on them the first is
the interaction of politics and law some
of you presumably a political scientist
some are legal scholars law and politics
are always in tension because law is
general it's universal and it's
normative it's supposed to apply
generally to a class of situations
without regard to their scripted
characteristics or their power politics
is not as most of politics is
non-normative it's opportunistic and it
certainly is power Lee so these are in a
continual tension with each other and
Richards comments just suggested that
tension there's never going to be
perfect justice because as vicinity said
let strong do what they can and the weak
suffer what they must now Katherine has
shown the strong don't always with it
there's some incursions on that oldest
but the sprong can do more and so if we
think about the intersection of politics
and law there were political conditions
that Katherine mentioned for normally
power shift that made it possible to
take always action law then provided an
opening for norm entrepreneurs that's
really important law is normative it
gives a handle people like you grab imma
say look we've got these these laws why
don't you apply over here why aren't you
playing these powerful and that's a very
Perry
strong very strong handle and domestic
politics then comes in four pails
pressures for change if you weren't
working in a democracy it didn't have a
large democracy behind you you wouldn't
make it anyway because the domestic
politics also well we have domestic
principal here up Marci why are they
being applied internationally so the
powerful powerful leverage here and then
and then long can turn sometimes can
create institutions like the ICC which
take these little openings that you get
and then widen them because you have an
institutional base and you can bring
cases and got principles and judges
operate but you always have to realize
that power disparities are always going
to push back we're always gonna be so
it's always going to be the case in my
view that there will be justice
disparities so someone could say 50
years from now even if we made a lot a
lot of progress it'll still be true that
there's not perfect balance of justice
between the poor and the Adventist
advantage of those be I read recently a
comment on a very good paper by Maximo
Langer who is that Argentina said trying
to know who's at NYU this year he looks
at universal jurisdiction and he finds
that there are lots of cases lots of
complaints over a thousand complaints
his catalogue systematically 32 trials
and 28 of them are of former Nazis
rondon's Afghans from the 80's and Serbs
in other words these people don't have
States to support them the states are
defunct or discredited so the filtering
process is still a process in which
states really play a major role in it so
you're not politics at all it's what
fascinates me about the whole subject
the second issue range of issues which
you touch on maybe we can talk about it
more I won't talk about long is that
well and what I love about this project
is about change in world politics and
one of the pathologies of international
ations theory until you came along and
some other people you particularly
catherine was that they let the
conventional wisdom was as Kenneth waltz
put it patterns repeat themselves and
Leslie and it's America Ron goes around
to get it again the animals are painted
a little bit different colors
but it's the same thing and of course
there's something to that times today us
and Vietnam are in rapprochement which
other why is that balance of power
theory explains it perfectly China is
getting bigger and more assertive so
it's a real truth here but and but much
of IR theory has over emphasized that
all branches realism I just cited
institutional theory often talks about
how institutions persist and how they
affect behavior and how they're hard to
change the legacies of institutions are
difficult to get rid of the
constructivist notion mostly it's not
about change it's about appropriateness
what behavior is appropriate and that's
also a static story so the hope that
this this this work catherine is doing
is a wedge for more systematic
discussion i think of change in world
politics in this area and others and
that's a another way in which you're
exercising leadership a third point I
wanted to make my next to last one was
suggested by what you were saying today
about essentially I interpreted you as
saying that this it wasn't even imagined
20 25 years ago 30 years ago that this
sort of process of individual
accountability of people in high
positions and states could be instituted
and so even activists without no no
don't say that it's just too scared it's
just too ridiculous people think we're
utopians and this raises a question
which we haven't really talked about in
worldpost enough for what are the
boundaries of imagination and how do
ideas about what is possible change and
this happened long ago with the League
of Nations it was certainly thought a
hundred hundred years ago probably a
certain 110 years ago the notion of
having a League of Nations was it was
absurd you wouldn't have a serious
conversation about it until probably
around 1910 and the notion of formal
adjudication in the WTO with binding
adjudication in a legal process I
thought that was not so and I'm an
institutionalist I'm not a realist 25
years ago I wouldn't have thought that
was going to happen it happened several
years later so we should be talking a
little bit also about perception and
reality so often we our perceptions that
something is impossible or true and very
often people are not so it's not going
to happen
but we ought to think a little more
about when when the change in
perceptions of what is possible actually
can create an opening and opening for
possibility and my last point just you
know briefly is about something
interests me particularly now about
persuasion there's been some work on
persuasion in student in city in world
phones I don't think it's terribly
persuasive because it's focused mostly
on what I what I call direct persuasion
I one leader tries to persuade another
leader of something problem is that
leaders are well and very well informed
they have very clear notions of what
their interests are and they're
therefore not very subject to persuasion
it's also true John mearsheimer is a new
book coming out when she shows he went
and looked at lying in international
politics and he thought he'd find lots
of lying being good hardly a hard-nosed
realist he found very little lying the
same reason why should I lie to you if
you know him if you know I'm lying to
you if you know I know I'm lying to you
what good does it do me in talking to
you as a head of state to lie to you
it's like I'm not gonna do much good or
or try to persuade you basically however
i think is not enough discussion of what
i call indirect persuasion that is most
people audiences are non-strategic
actors there there's no reason to act
strategically if you're one of 300
million people who are responding to
Martin Luther King's talk or to a Kofi
Annan's talk and yet if you change your
mind because in furthermore you're not
very well inform so a small amount of
information might change your mind you
could then in a Democratic Society put
pressure on leaders who then even if
they don't change their minds behave as
if they did because they're responding
to political pressure so I think I might
like guess is that behind the story
you're telling there are a lot of
stories about indirect persuasion in
which norm entrepreneurs and the
political leaders whom they include a
recruit or influence persuade large
audiences of non-strategic actors and
Democratic public's to change their view
on what's possible and what should be
done and these people then put pressure
on political leaders and that that's the
process much more
direct persuasion process but something
is underlying the story you're telling
and I'm trying to make some suggestions
about getting at that while you're
collecting to do that well I do have
comments but since this isn't standing
there maybe we should have you go ahead
you sure I'm happy just no hands go
ahead for you just I think it's time for
it it's always great to okay look it and
fall from um I have one just sort of
factual question and then something that
follow us on something that bob has
already said um I had been persuaded by
bronwyn Lee Bowers analysis of Nuremberg
where she takes Dida sklar's analysis of
legalism that is the same dividual
criminal accountability is being
established then and then names that
human rights legalism as it comes so I'm
just curious about where you disagree
with her because you start the you know
yours is in the third wave and then I
was also very I'm so pleased that Bob
focus on causal mechanisms because
without reading the manuscript I didn't
know whether they were there but they
weren't there in the talk and so I think
particularly for policy recommendations
and there are a lot of us in the world
in this room even who are wanting to
have influence on on this practical
operational world that Richards talking
about I think we need to know what the
causal mechanism so we can give
effective recommendations and and for
that I wanted to hear more
disaggregation of some of your
categories and then help me think
through what I presume are different
causal mechanisms in each case in terms
of effectiveness or even causal ones
that is
so why do we get the Cascade in the way
you say the first is that I as I
understand it and please correct me I
saw your category of domestic
prosecutions as being two separate types
one in countries where the abuses
violations actually happened in
Argentina and another where other
domestic jurisdictions like Britain on
panoche took up the case I would assume
that those are quite different in terms
of certainly in terms of effectiveness
but it influenced and maybe even caused
the second is in in your data and your
your description the regional factor
keeps coming up over and over again as
if it's important so what are your theme
what why would the regional it's in your
diffusion it's in your chronologies it's
it's quite a number of things so it
doesn't really matter is that just
happens to be interesting in terms of
the cases and the third and for me the
most important is I because i work on
civil wars and post-conflict
transitional justice is two very
different categories for Minas Rudy
titles understanding ER and then there's
the post-cold war stuff those are very
different understandings of transitional
justice including the role that these
courts should play and prosecution to
play and then I also don't think of
human rights as necessarily a part of
those two so I first wanted to say well
there's human rights in this
transitional justice but because I think
of transitional justice is at least two
separate categories in terms of thinking
about mechanisms I'd like to hear you
just help me think through how your data
apply to that differentiation because um
this idea I think it is a false debate
whether it's individual states or member
states on the Security Council whether
people are not between peace and justice
it really does depend upon what it is
that we're talking about and what our
objective is it might very well be that
the mechanisms for transitional justice
in post-conflict are
better achieve by non tribunal non
individual criminal for example that is
different from transitions among regimes
which is quite different from
enforcement of international human
rights law yeah I think we should gather
a few questions baby or comments Thanks
I have a two-part question actually the
first one if I understand these graphs
actually correctly then this is a subset
of countries and then maybe it's
unconscious going in and out there was
entirely clear on that but I was
wondering whether you could tell us what
those graphs would look like when we
looked at all countries or maybe all non
democracies and here's why I'm asking so
beyond the immediate effect in states
that actually have trial experience I
would think if I'm North Italian ruler
or part of the ruling repressing elite
and I see these trials in true easily
going on and I observe some kind of form
of a norm against these forms of
repression and I'm seeing that I may
actually be called to justice at some
point later even if I travel either if I
travel abroad angry without proper care
or or maybe because it's going to be a
regime change within my own country I'm
going to be more careful and so I would
expect that if these norms actually have
a deterrence effect then even these
average values should show some kind of
declining over time at least after the
norm becomes effective and I was curious
whether whether you have any indication
that that's taken place the second and
some words have brought a question that
that made me wonder about is do we have
any good theoretical reasons to expect a
particular time lag there's how much
time should pass after the beginning of
these new practices or maybe the
intensive diffusion of these practices
before we actually should see behavioral
changes as a consequence and i'm not
sure we we do and and then ultimately of
course
a lot of the sort of empirical
assessment of that but require actually
really to work through that theoretical
logic first thank you a couple of
questions in your previous work you have
dealt with the issue of gender and and
but I wonder to what extent your current
concerns deal with that issue in
particular that many of the gender
issues or violations of gender issues
are non governmental and to what extent
your new framework accounts for for
explaining the grievances and the
violations of gender rights and so
that's one question and my second
question deals with the current colonial
encounters in in in the current
international settings namely their
relationships between Israel and
Palestine and the Israeli expansion and
an ever expanding into the Palestinian
rights and Palestinian existence and
whether or not your model explains
violations against Palestinian rights
thank you well
maybe I should there's so many
interesting questions and comments that
people are given so what maybe I should
try to just briefly try to address a few
of the point that people have made and
so I'm very sympathetic to Richard's
points about the the idea that that
justice that this is a fragile process
and as a power laiden process and in the
on this particular issue I think that
that bob has said it as I wouldn't met
as a political scientist never expects
power to go away uh and that the kind of
analysis I do maybe I can just briefly
briefly do this oops no okay there
because the kind of us i do most human
rights activists most victims do
something i'll call comparison to the
ideal they say what's what you know what
kind of Justice do we have compared to
my ideal of justice and if by definition
we always fall short okay so it's always
a pessimistic receptionist is how far
short do we do a lot of this is about
counterfactual reasoning and that is the
whole you know the whole argument of the
ICC in Sudan or in Uganda is all
counterfactual reasoning you know so if
someone says the indictment of bar shear
has been made work has made worse a
situation in Sudan then it would have
been the contracts then it would have
been without the indictment other people
make the exact opposite they say no the
situation Sudan is better today than it
would have been without the ICC
involvement we can't resolve that and so
I do this empirical comparison and I go
from where we were where we started to
where we are today and when you do that
things you see what I believe is
progress and that's a not always a
popular word and international relations
theorists but I believe this constitutes
progress but I would totally agree with
that we're never we're never getting
there we're never getting to our ideals
and I think it's appropriate to when
people talk make those things say well
we're concerned here about change in
world politics and how we move from a
situation with with complete impunity to
situation where there is much less
there's certainly less imputing than
there was but we will never get to a
situation where there's complete justice
and certainly not where there's
even-handed justice I'm going to the
question of the many interesting points
you've made Bob the one that I want to
turn to its question about persuasion
and that's because so the issue is what
makes some arguments persuasive and some
not persuasive and political scientists
haven't been able to address this and
it's because I think we won't address
the trim in trinsic power of ideas that
particular ideas might have intrinsic
power and be more persuasive than other
ideas we don't want to do that because
it's so hard because once you say that
you say what what intrinsic quality has
that and an activist be on board as you
know I made an argument that bodily harm
to vulnerable populations was an
intrinsic I trinsic Lee powerful idea
that was going to be able to be more
persuasive than other ideas and this is
another area where we have we talking
about bodily harm but we're talking
about holding people accountable for
bodily harm to vulnerable populations so
I think there's two things that make
this issue persuasive the first is the
domestic analogy that I mentioned it's
persuasive because as soon as people can
imagine it that is possible they have a
model they hell model in their own
domestic judicial system that they take
for granted they say but of course
someone who murders someone should be
held criminally accountable it should be
sent to jail and so there's a
commonplace pneus that if you can just
get you can get rid of the idea that you
can't hold static officials accountable
there's a commonplace nas's idea that I
think has made it persuasive and
explains why we've seen more movement on
this idea than many other ideas
international
politics and then secondly there's this
you know this interesting debate over
the moral instinct but people say that
part that there are the you know that
that this desire for desire to see that
Norm breakers get punished is actually
very very widely shared deeply across
cultures so okay on these thank you for
the very interesting questions and again
I can't answer all of them so let me try
to answer at least one from each person
you know that I want to let me talk
about the regional factor because that
interests me most what you know I'm not
the only political scientist in fact
that Simmons who will be here in the
next talk and many other political
scientists are really picking up on
regional effects nowadays and mainly
diffusion diffusion theories are showing
a lot of regional effects and the truth
is I think we don't know why so I think
we're seeing regional effects but we
don't understand why we're seeing
regional effects we don't know region as
a proxy for we suspect regions approxi
or something else but we don't know what
and you know so Bob's there's a wonder
Singh thing that maybe the Latin America
you know I've seen this regional effect
in Latin America because virtually all
the Latin countries participated in the
second wave of democracy and so now what
we're catching is this regional fact is
partly that their third wave countries
that also had second wave experiences
that could be it I in my research see
this role fees Regional Human Rights
institutions those institutions may also
have been created as a result of a prior
democratic experience the prior
commitment to human rights right but
it's very interesting the role the
inter-american Commission of Human
Rights is played in Latin America for
example very almost surprising to me
what an important role they played so
building these humans institutions which
are some scene is empty exercises at
least in my kids trying to be very
important to do things they weren't set
up to do which is criminal
accountability the inter-american Court
is a state accountability court and yet
dinner Rican Commission in every country
in Latin America that use prosecutions
there was a prior report later
commissioned calling on them to hold
domestic trials and hold these people
criminally accountable to the extent of
the possible extent of the law so so the
question about you know why am I only
using a subset of countries I'm only
looking at transitional countries
oh um I do have a second database of all
countries in the world and i'm not using
that for our statistical analysis and
i'm not using it because it I don't I
don't trust all the trials especially in
authoritarian countries you know so I it
was it's listed as a trial but we can't
really tell in these authoritarian
context whether it's kind of a kangaroo
trial or whether it's a vengeance trial
or whatever but if I gave you the data
of all the countries of the world that
trend is even more dramatic okay even
more dramatic then the trend i showed
you here so i do have some data on that
that's just this is a global trend that
it's not limited to transitional
societies and it's happening both in
fully democratic societies and in
authoritarian societies as well so now
then you sort of said would I expect the
humanoids average values to decline in
the world okay even though I used that
that I'm using those human rights scores
I have another article where I critique
the scores not because I think they're
unreliable but kind of gave it a
systematic bias the human rights
reporting as a systematic bias towards
making things seem worse why because
we've hugely Morton not only that when
my co-author and Clark is right here in
the audience i'm writing this article
with and Clark and I are arguing that
there's a systematic information effect
because what's happened over the last 30
years is that we have so much more
information about human rights
violations and we used to have and so
it's possible that some of these
repression numbers it's not that human
rights is getting worse in the world
it's that we have know a lot more about
human rights than we did before now what
that means is that it's even harder to
get the statistical result that I got
with this data it's even harder to show
that anything leads to improvements and
so when you show that the things lead to
improvements you're fighting against
that information effect in the data okay
but what that was just why it is we
don't see a trend why that global Human
Rights repression line isn't trending
downward and probably won't trend
downward
as long and then finally the issue about
a question about gender gender enters
into this analysis mainly in the way
that is entered into the prosecution's
and as people know from of the
International and ad hoc tribunals they
have been very important for
incorporating issues like an
understanding of rape as a war crime and
that the Rome Statute in fact has been I
think made particularly important
advances with really incorporating
gender issues and gender crimes for the
first time into our understanding of
crimes against humanity and war crimes
and not only that but there has been
some increased because of I think air is
made early on in prosecutions there's
been increased sensitivity in dealing
with victims and providing testimony in
tribunals to be particularly sensitive
to trauma that victims experience and I
don't think that they're you know that
they're doing a great job still but I
think there has been really increased
sensitivity about how to handle highly
traumatized victims including victims of
gender crimes so that they can provide
testimony in these tribunals so there is
a gender dimension here we're not seen
prosecution for gender crimes as much in
domestic tribunals as we are in
international tribunals and that's an
interesting fact that I haven't analyzed
yet Michael yeah
I need you
with all of the commentator and so far
it sounds like a wonderful book I look
forward to reading it if you're dealing
with my same editor at nor deny
understand why it's difficult to push
back in just quite the way the bob is
recommended if you do something the two
questions once a policy question and the
other is analytic question on the
analytic question you had the graph up
there where trials took place didn't
take place whether they were short term
or long term and you show some very
interesting trends out there in some of
the debates people argue that trials
have another effect slightly different
from deterrence or persuasion or norm
expression is that they have good
short-run effects if they take place
because they take the thugs off the
streets they lock them up and so you'll
have a reduction in repression that
takes place as a short-run effect but
then eventually the deeper underlying
tensions of society reemerge and they go
back to repression and conflict etc the
other theory is quite different they
said if you have trials than people push
back and it either leads to a break a
war again which is increasing repression
and violence or street-level violence
takes place that makes for a scheme of
repression and it's only in the long run
when a set of trials if they do take
place set the record straight and they
preclude nationalist Smith making you
know how many people did the Croatian
Nazis Serbs actually kill in 1943 or 44
turns out to be important in 1990 so on
the one hand they expect a big short-run
effect and a little long run effect and
then on the other hand a negative short
run in effect but a positive long-run
effect somewhat my question is does your
data allow you to lag the the period
between the trial and then the measure
of repression can you add 10 years for
example to it do you go far enough back
to allow that to happen and if you do
what did you find or if you didn't what
do you think you might find if you
did that kind of exercise the the second
question is a policy question and this
is back to Bashir in Sudan a Harold Koh
was visiting columbia law school
yesterday and gave of his pitch for why
Obama is better than bush on the rule of
law he persuaded everybody in the room
on his basic thesis needles to say I
pressed him a little bit on Sudan and I
asked him the following question that
there's been talk of normalization with
Sudan if the referendum in the South
Sudan proceeds in an orderly fashion and
there is no military reaction to the
outcome that is if they had North allows
the south to secede under some terms and
doesn't invade it take the oil back and
that the question I asked him is what is
normalization mean and does it mean
lifting of the indictment of Bashir and
Harold is the good lawyer he is rattled
off without a blink three legal reasons
why it could be lifted just just like
that I don't think you were interested
in them but the crush the thing that
struck me is that this is not the first
time he's thought about that question
President Obama met with heads of state
on September 17th or 18th on the issue
of Sudan right here in New York and so
the question is presumably the lifting
indictment is on the table Harold thinks
it could be done legally and the
question is is this a good idea or not
given what you've studied about the role
of trials and in peace
I'm also looking forward very much to
reading your book and the thought that
occurred to mean I think professor
Kahane just touched on it in his very
interesting comments is one that is of
interest to practitioners in terms of
what sort of advice one gives in these
sort of situations I think your
distinction between ruptured and pack
two transitions is a key distinction
that may lead to other explanatory
aspects and and I guess and I haven't
done any research on this one I guess
the trials of course tend to happen more
in the ruptured situations and the truth
and reconciliation Commission's tend to
happen more in the packet situations so
what I think would be interesting in
your in your squiggly lines is to ask
yourself let's look at those pected
situations where you did have a Truth
and Reconciliation Commission and ask
yours asked the same question what sort
of impact did it have because if it is
distinguishable amongst the non trial
holding countries then you're looking at
another policy option in terms of the
advice one gives to the the country's
going through transition well I'm going
to start with that one just because we
actually have done we actually have look
at that question and there's another
research project that my colleague lee
pain is doing and she's also looked at
it and we have contrary contradictory
results on that question so hundred Kim
and I looked and we found that truth
commissions were also associated with
some improvements in human rights very
often countries do both trials and truth
Commission's by the way and so even
though there's this notion that you do
one piece that you do justice or truth
it turns out that most all the countries
in Latin America that held prosecutions
also had truth commissions for example
so more often truth commissions and
trials are used together and then
there's countries that do little or do
nothing but nevertheless we we were able
of truth commissions
and we found a positive impact Lee pain
however found a negative impact of truth
commissions and we think it's because we
code slightly differently we only code
truth Commission's that have reports
published reports and she'd been coding
truth Commission's whether or not they
have published reports and it could be
that a truth commission with a published
report is actually more sincere a truth
commission that you would expect it to
have an impact and indeed that's what
we're seeing but so that but that's
exactly one that's we're trying to get
at this difference between punishment
and and normative communication because
the truth Commission's only are only
normative communication there's no
punishment involved and so if the
mechanisms goes to Susan's point it's a
mechanism is norm communication then we
would expect both truth commissions and
trials to work if it's punishment then
we expect only trials to work and in
fact only trials with convictions to
work and we're not seeing that we're
seeing that the whole process of
prosecution even shorter convictions but
for example Milosevic a trial no
conviction so when people only Codding
is the only coding virtus convictions
they've code nothing most which doesn't
count it's big zero and we think that'd
be a big mistake p no Chet no conviction
no verdict we think that'd be a big
mistake because there's this
communicative process as well so
basically the we don't have a good
answer for you yet on that one but it's
a really important question what we are
seeing is that the combination of trials
and truth Commission's or tends to be
particularly effective in tends to be
very common and it we do think it's that
old dichotomy that's not useful truth
versus justice it it's usually not the
case you have to choose one or the other
or the countries do um okay my Michaels
point that's really interesting point
about tongue about short verses long-run
effects we do look we do lag and we do
look effects over a ten-year period we
do see that countries that make more
persistent use of trial so one trial
versus more persistent use of trials do
see a bigger effect up to a certain
point and then there seems to be
diminishing returns
um and so we don't see that they have
good short run and then it disappears
and so but this relates to I think the
earlier question about how long would we
expect it to take and I've been thinking
because of you know my knowledge kind of
Latin American case is more of
generational effects that in fact the
perpetrators themselves the deterrence
Theory actually sometimes refers to it
as a not as deterrence but
incapacitation you said you want to in
pet your goodbyes incapacitate them
because in fact they are not objects of
deterrence someone has already committed
a crime is not an object deterrence they
can only be in capacity hind but the
people were interested in the next
generation military leaders or security
force or police leaders in Latin America
or coming up through the ranks and who
are looking at that and saying maybe
it's not a good career choice to do that
and if it's if it's a generational fact
we would expect a lag as that new
generation comes in and then the harder
question that I didn't know this about
about Harold um okay this is what I
think one I've already explained that I
think the interpretations of what's
going on in Sudan or Uganda are entirely
based on counter factual arguments okay
it's an entirely counter factual
argument that if you lift the indictment
against Bashir that things are going to
get better and Sudan okay some people
say it some people say the opposite we
partly only have Bashir's word for it
okay in other words the dilemma with
hacking Bashir's word for it is that
purse I mean I think in the strictly
technical sense of the blackmailer okay
that basically Bashir is saying you
indict me I will you no harm UN troops I
will unleash war okay so basically how
this guy who's black nearly national
system to try to get rid of something he
really doesn't like which is an
indictment and my other people will be
better experts in this but my hunch is
that giving in but one believing
Bashir's counterfactual as the one that
we accept we US policymakers we smart
people like Harold Koh
are going to buy hiral are going to buy
a Bashir's counterfactual that only if
we lift the indictment well things get
better will there be peace and sit in
question secondly it you know have we do
we believe that giving in to blackmail
is the best way it's so you see that
it's different because it's because it's
implicit blackmail so the implicit
blackmail is that that okay
yeah my feeling is that Bashir is not a
I would not trust what he says yeah I
would not trust what he says of course
he wants to get rid of the indictment of
course he will do everything possible in
his power to get rid of the indictment
that's what we would expect that's what
a political time to expect now will he
keep his word what I'm not sure why we
expect to keep his word and i'm not sure
why lifting the indictment would make
him keep his word become so i would be
very hesitant i think it'd be a mistake
i think the issue is that as i think bob
has pointed out you know law will always
be influenced by politics but law
disciplines politics and sounds to me
like would take legal gymnastics even
for helko to do that ah and that we
would lose that disciplining power of
lie think you know that I think powerful
states should do what they need to do to
deal with Bashir the United States
England they can all bilaterally or
multilaterally negotiate with Bashir and
they can give him what he wants and give
them the deal they want what they
shouldn't do is try to turn the ICC into
a tool into their tool because if
powerful state's attorney has to see
into their tool they've lost what's most
affected by the ICC and that's
effectively it's not it's an exercise of
law that not anything goes
so tonight we've gotten great analysis
we've done career advice and i want to
remind you of the advertisement we hope
to see you next wednesday the best in
law in the other venue same time but in
1501 internet in Clara's buildings so
thanks to Catherine